Brian
Anderson that was in the name of the
great Ric Flair
W what a game unbelievable uh and you
know what the Joker is joining us oh
really from San Francisco uh even as we
speak uh Nico yic what the heck was that
man
uh I mean it was a I'm one of the really
big comeback I think we were down 12 in
the last 3 40 to go I think they score
only three actually four point three
points in the last uh 3 340 something
like that so it was a really really nice
comeback wi for us we didn't give up
that's that's what I think this is one
of the best description of our we never
quit Joko we all know you're a very
unselfish player but when teams decide
not to double te team you are you a
shoot first guy or or do you still say
you know what I'm going just make a
couple dribbles make them double and
then try to pass or do you say oh you're
not going to double team me watch this I
mean I I I'm trying to read the game I'm
playing I think s since I came in a
league even even back home so I'm just
I'm just trying to to find open man or
if I'm open to to to
score Joker can I ask you a question did
you call Glass on that my
friend I'm
happy hey congratulations when you guys
you know uh Coach B Gand talked about it
you guys defense was great in the fourth
quarter you didn't play great def for
the first three quarters you played
great defense in the fourth quarter
that's really what turned the game
around correct yeah I mean yes even I
think we had a good sense like we have a
of course that those two are the one of
the best Shooters in the game so they
need something something a little bit
different in defensive coverage but uh I
we had we had a couple breakdowns and
that kind of get them get them going and
by the four quarter was amazing for us
and uh like you said that that's how
that's why he won the
game Joker since Shaq wouldn't do it
tonight
Kaki oh I like it good job good
job thank come on sh come on sh that was
your
thing he didn't come he was trying to do
it but I just got trying to do it but
dumb Underdog I told him to pack
it no worries no worries Kaki but uh I I
just would say oh overall you know you
guys are in a position right now where
everyone is still chasing you do you
feel there's anyone you're chasing as
the Denver Nuggets right now oh we are
chasing Denver Nuggets too we want to be
the better we want to be the better than
last year I think we were capable of
being better and to be the that team
this year so I think we are facing them
the
too Joker you know what you're shooting
over the last four
games I mean I think I know but
sometimes 39 for
44 sometimes the the ball goes in
sometimes not I had the one of the one
of the best shooting nights and one of
the worst so it is what it is uh hey
look we appreciate you spending some
time with us incredible finish
incredible shot uh nice going man thank
you thank you
guys no it's not sh come on brother it's
second
time oh that's right that's rup I'm
sorry all over the place we apologize
bye have a good night Li don't y'all
Master English first I was correct good
job Underdog I was correct hey he was
legit I was legit when he when he heard
you it was very good Kenny which we've
never I've been practicing we've never
heard him say I've been
practicing I've been practicing Hey
listen stick to English big fell stick
to English all right let's take a little
break and we'll come
back